welcome to this video playing home birth
to more yano from Argentina let's see
Kings Indian fianchetto or that black is
not committed yet to specific set up he
can also go with C 5k 96 so we have this
this line had the panel variation yeah
if I'm not mistaking Paulo is actually
from Argentina so of a wuss don't think
he's alive anymore I hope I'm not
telling nonsense yeah but I think he was
really from Argentina okay playing
Bishop to d7 should I play Queen d2
Bishop 86 mmm yeah probably or do we
occupy the center he fork also comes
into consideration delayed you 45 or d5
immediately d5 night a 5 mm I like the
special h6 idea
if he goes e5 takes takes Bishop g5 is
is a pin that's not so easy to to break
let's see okay he goes for b5 it looks
that actually um in a way try to make
less attractive by putting the rukon see
one but he didn't really didn't really
he wasn't really deterred from that okay
Bishop age six i might play before him
on d5 i can always play D 5 D 5 9 a-5 be
three maybe it's not Keely am
maybe start with this I don't know
difficult difficult to to evaluate
what's the right right way to play your
night 85 m yeah this looks it looks
loose this night but it's not evident
how I should exploit this as I still
like to play this one make sure that
night c4 is not coming okay this one I
hear this I'm probably need to take
should takes
I Queen to h4 Bishop g5 for this kind of
idea maybe 94 at the right moment tough
i'm not i'm not sure how to play this
maybe you can even play before him yeah
I am I probably should have played a 94
earlier I have no no good move really I
have to go here the a Quincy five was a
real level a bad idea probably really
just a bad idea if i go here that's even
95 coming
yeah maybe I love Bishop to e3 store
maybe maybe a night move but now k95 I
have no g5 this is not not helping it
much maybe Nyjah 5 is an idea anyway 92
95 maybe I can get some pressure against
a h7 but with my night on b1 I can never
be in very good shape here maybe just 94
94 I can maybe no I can maybe take on c6
because of those pins well why does this
I I not even remotely considered okay
he just allows me to take this it's not
clear that it helps me in any way but
still I didn't expect that take he's
directly attacking my pony on e2 still
probably should take this hmm how do I
keep the poem should have three not very
attractive but yeah I don't I didn't see
anything else hmm yeah and the bishop
the night is probably coming to 85 m
let's see for here maybe maybe check I
can take here and put something and 95
probably
not too great not a great performance
yeah i mean like it's a very very okay
maybe I can always actually weakening
this structure a bit defy the sir maybe
a problem sometimes takes takes I cannot
take you five I can check here take care
take before maybe
ok he has you six and this is not so
easy to play time morning night is good
on c4 just want to keep controlling this
position f form being on possibility the
eight hang so we cannot take can I take
before I can also go here right check
maybe you can try d three but I can just
take it everything else fails check
check queen bee 724 hmm how do i how do
i get to his his King
black forfeits on time yeah i also have
Queenie seven coming so it's it's it's
all okay now this wasn't a good good
position really I couldn't really find a
good good middle game plan probably hear
the screen g5 is just just a stupid idea
here I should should look for look for
improvements I don't think that white
should should be able to claim anything
special but I should be should be equal
at least compounds to go night g5 not a
very natural this looks more normal but
yeah before somewhat annoying i always
have to misplace my night yeah this is
probably equal this is not a good idea I
look beef is also here here this was a
surprising move Bishop b5 here I also
could have taken before which I didn't
really consider at all okay it's not
totally clear however i can play
something like this renewing this idea
okay 94 ah very very nice move does this
I didn't see of course at all night f5
this is very nice he cannot take 25 is
made and yeah what's what should he do
97 is a maid threat that's very nice
compounds to do this and why this is
much better difficult line to see yeah I
didn't see it at all
but here the definitely the the worst is
over for me I should be really okay now
Bishop is seven interesting okay and
this is probably not leading to to
anything yeah yeah maybe leading to
problems leading to problems i guess but
he didn't didn't make any use of it and
here I think I'm definitely okay check I
should probably take right here he
definitely should play six I believe
this is not not cleared or the compass
just giving this is equal interestingly
enough i have fair this porn but it's
not an easy task technically the pawns
are very far behind they're not
promoting quickly and black has a
healthy structure and good sent down
this is not easy this is helping me
enormously getting the night that his
sort of worsening his own bishop i
Knight b6 okay I was keen to play some
quick moves to get to get total control
anything I managed so I'm okay with that
not be six is better but keeping control
is also worth something okay thanks for
watching